[Applause]
hey everyone my name is Reyes I'm a
postdoc at Harvard I want to talk about
some very cool work we've been doing at
Wayfarer this is a joint work with Chris
Ferreira who's a faculty member at HBS
and soon and apart SRD who's a associate
director of data science at wafer the
problem that I want to talk about today
is pretty simple how should an
e-commerce platform rank products on its
webpage I think fancy about it so far
and the reason this belongs in an
information design workshop is that
people on the internet have unlimited
patients and they want to look at
everything you throw at them no I'm just
kidding people on the internet have a
very short attention span so really what
rank that you choose the ranking of
products that you choose determines what
they see and you get to effect purchase
decisions by controlling the information
that people see this is a this is not a
particularly new problem so let me kind
of motivate it with a slightly different
setup than the kind of problems you'd
see usually the platform that we work
with is Wayfarer Wayfarer if you want if
you have not heard of it before it's
kind of like Amazon but mostly for home
goods like Amazon Wave where people go
on wafer they search and purchase
products but wafer also has these themed
events which are somewhat different I
guess you can't read very clearly on the
screen but essentially each event is
like a short sale it has a finite
collection assortment of products that
are chosen beforehand the prices are
fixed beforehand usually on sale and the
only thing that we can do is kind of
affect the ranking of products within
this event these events are kind of all
over the place some of them are pretty
specific like rugs that you see here
some of them are kind of pretty generic
like Halloween events or like pet crates
or something like that
budget-friendly sectionals why is this
an interesting setting well like I
mentioned the customers who come on this
platform come for these events don't
really know what the products are
beforehand but the platform needs to
select a good enough ranking to get
their attention fast that's kind of the
main Challenger and if people don't like
what they see they're gonna leave very
soon
the other things that make this
challenging is that the users who come
to these events are usually first-timers
or people who haven't engaged with the
platform as much so the platform or weed
algorithm designers don't know what
their preferences are before handling
finally these events are short-lived
so in the previous page most of these
events were under a week you can see the
ends and five days ends in so the
mechanism that we design has to converge
to an optimal ranking it has to learn
what the preference of users are and it
has to converge pretty fast because the
events are short-lived
that's kind of the challenge you're
facing here let me dive right into the
model you have a bunch of customers and
you have a bunch of products each
customer has two parameters a vector of
quick probabilities and an attention
window the customers behavior is going
to be as follows you the platform shows
the customer ranking pipe now initially
the customer is neutral about the event
so they're gonna go through products 1
through K remember that K can be
different for different customers now as
long as they are neutral they're gonna
click on each product that they see
within the top attention window with
probability P I T where I is the
customer sorry I if the product and T is
the customer if you don't even elicit a
single click from them within your
attention window the customer decides
that the event is not for them so they
quit and we say that this customer is
not hooked if the customer likes at
least one event within the detention
window and clicks on it the customer is
hooked in which case we impose no
restrictions on the behavior so hope
customer can go on clicking lots of
products can stay for longer than KT and
so on no assumptions on that view the
inter couple of interesting things here
that I want you guys to note here is
that the attention window is different
for different users and the attention
window is correlated with the
Preferences so the reasoning for this is
think of someone like a mobile user
these users tend to be young and this
did this affects both the products they
liked and their attention spans because
you have short attention spans
we run through a very very quick example
this is super deterministic so all the
probabilities of zero or one you have
exactly two products this one is ranked
1 this one is ranked 2 you have 3 users
these guys have an attention window of
two this person has an attention window
of 1 so what happens on the platform is
that the first two people come the
product that they like is ranked 1
that's great they click on the product
you're hooked back from Vince
unfortunately look at the third user
this person comes on a platform the
product that they like is that position
2 but their attention window is only one
so the first product that they see is
going to be this one they think oh man
maybe this event is not so hot and they
leave the platform and they not hooked
now if you're paying attention you can
very easily see that if I swap the order
I can hook all three users at the same
time but if you look at just popularity
metrics these this product is the most
popular one because it appeals to
two-thirds of your user base so the kind
of easy takeaway here is that ordering
products by their property or their
click probability is suboptimal
hopefully the setting everyone's ok with
the setting our goal here is the
following you have customers arrive
sequentially the platform needs to
select a ranking for each customer and
our goal is to maximize the number of
hooked customers remember that a
customer is hooked if they click on one
or more products and they like the event
so maximizing a number of customers is
equivalent to minimizing the number of
people who abandon the event because
they didn't like what they see if
everyone's okay with this objective we
know that the ranking back popularity
does not work so what kind of algorithm
does work let's start a little bit naive
and then that's gonna dive into the
actual algorithm so let's fix product
sequentially in ranks 1 through n so
let's say that at this point you're
fixed products at ranks 1 2 & 3 and
you're deciding which product to have in
rank 4 now you have three choices
product 1 2 & 3 the naive idea is that
you try all three of them in rank 4 and
you pick the best one and sabri the
algorithm basically so you pick the one
that kind of maximizes the marginal
utility at this position
this algorithm does okay but
unfortunately it's too slow and like I
mentioned we need some fast approach so
we're going to combine this naive greedy
approach and some sort of a threshold
based dropping criteria the kind this
gives you a 1/2 approximation if if the
preferences are correlated and 1 minus 1
over e if they're independent so we're
going to try something a little bit more
clever we're gonna fix a threshold tau
instead of trying all the products I'm
gonna scan through the products in some
predetermined clever order and the first
time I hit a product that hopes at least
tau users or has a click probability
marginal utility of tau I'm gonna fix
that here and then I move on to the next
position the advantage of this compared
to the naive algorithm is that I don't
have to try all the products in this
position instead in one pass through
this to the list of products I can fix
multiple ranks so see what happens like
if I go through this product and this
product I can fix this one here and then
I tried this one for rank 5 and I fix it
here so this offers quite the speed-up
in compared to your naive greedy
algorithm let me just quickly sum up
what the result is essentially this
converges reasonably fast it gives you a
1/2 approximation plus an alpha factor
if the preferences and attention spans
are correlated and if they are
independent this improves to 1 minus 1
over 8 we have a lot of other cool
algorithms in the paper so you guys can
go check it out let me spend like one
minute talking about the data analysis
part because this was pretty challenging
so we came up with an algorithm we
wanted to test it wafer gave us access
to your data everything is great
unfortunately the problem was that this
was click data so all we had was you
have historical events and you have all
the products that people clicked on now
how on earth do you infer customer
preferences from this click data because
if you want to test the algorithm you
need to infer what the preferences are
and if the economists in the room have a
cool answer to this I'd be happy to hear
them but we tried something that's
fairly simple we essentially did some
sort of a Bayesian inference to
map each user with zero clicks to a
preference profile of a clicked user and
the algorithm actually did ok in
practice we got anywhere between 5 and
30 percent improvement okay to sum up
people on the Internet are like bored
teenagers and we came up a tiny toy stew
kind of get them hooked on the platform
the other I think maintenance slide is
that a lot of this learning to rank
literature for people who are familiar
proposes ranking products by their
intrinsic popularity or clique
probabilities this may not necessarily
be a good approach if your customer base
is heterogeneous or if they have short
attention spans so that's something to
keep in mind we tried more rigorous
simulation methods but I think if people
have an idea on how to use quick data to
come up with customer preferences I'd
love to hear them thank you
[Applause]
this is joint work with two students
Jerian Raj Wong who is was an
undergraduate last year and is a
applying for PhD this year and David
like numbering who was a PhD student at
Kok Cornell and has graduated so we have
I'm going to talk about information
design with the risk conscious agents
and I need to specify what I mean by
that so before I do that let me start
off with a very standard framework for
Bayesian persuasion so the typical
assumption here is that there is some
unknown state of the world which we'll
call let's call it Omega and there is a
receiver and the assumption is the
receiver is Bayesian and expected
utility Maximizer
has some prior about Omega right and
must choose an action a right and there
is a sender who observes Omega right and
shares information about Omega to the
receiver before the receiver chooses
their action right and once the receiver
gets the information they update their
belief according to Bayes rule and
choose an optimal action subsequent to
that and the goal of the sender is to
maximize the expected utility their own
expected utility which depends on the
unknown state of the world as well as
the action chosen by the receiver right
so from a practical standpoint the thing
to remember a thing to consider here
would be a sender is the platform and
the receiver is a user or a customer and
the unknown state of the world could be
lets say the congestion or the waiting
time things like that okay and the
sender's goal might be to get the
receiver to avail the service right so
what we do in our work is basically
relax this assumption that the receiver
is an expected utility Maximizer and for
lack of a better term I'm going to call
them risk conscious but if there are any
better terms I don't want to call them
non expected utility Maximizer again and
again so I'm just calling them less
conscious and what do I mean by a risk
conscious agent
so let's just think about this suppose
the state unknown state can take one of
three values and this this triangle
denotes the probability simplex right
and this is every point here is a belief
of the receiver and the expected utility
maximizers basically says that utility
is linear in your belief right so in
particular I denote the indifference
curves and these are all hyperplanes and
there is consideration basically says
that the utility could be any nonlinear
function of their belief right so no
restriction pretty general and what are
the motivation we have already seen a
lot of talk today that basically talk
about extensive empirical evidence that
human behavior is not adequately
explained by expected utility
maximization and especially when it
comes to like these service systems
where the customers are basically
deciding whether to wait for service it
is known from a literature on psychology
of waiting that customers typically
perceived uncertain wait times to be
longer than definite wait times right
and this suggests that the variance of
the wait time impacts their decision
whether to wait avail service or not and
variance is something that can't be
incorporated into the expected utility
framework another motivation that we
have for studying this is that a
receiver could not just be one single
agent but they could be a group of
agents and their behavior comes out of
some equilibrium behavior for example
right and in that case assuming that
they are an expected utility Maximizer
is not not the right thing to do right
so the question that we have is that
what are the implications here for
information design when the receiver is
not an expected utility maximizing do
talk about that let me briefly go over
how the analysis works for expected
utility maximizes so one of the first
step that one needs to do is to identify
the signals that need to be sent to the
receiver by the sender what is the
optimal set of signals right then the
argument is goes through basically
through a revelation principle style
argument
so so let's say again we have the space
of beliefs and suppose the receiver has
to choose one of two actions right and
suppose all the blue lines are beliefs
that induce the optimal action to be won
and the red ones are the optimal action
to be 0 and the argument goes that if
there are two signals that the sender
sends for which the receivers optimal
action is 1 right if they just revealed
that the signal is 1 of s1 s2 instead of
telling which one it is
right the receivers belief would be
something on the line joining the two
induced beliefs right this is just Bayes
rule property of Bayes rule
so basically coalescing signals like
this does not change the optimal action
right so what you can do is call as all
signals correspond that lead to the same
optimal action into a single action
recommendation just tell people or
choose this action and choose that
action so this helps quite a bit in
specifically all you need is one signal
for action in this case right and in
fact you can use this to show that the
sender's problem reduces to a linear
program with some obedience constraint
that basically say that whenever I'm
supposed to tell you to choose action a
it is in your interest to choose action
a so let's see what happens with the
risk conscious agents right it's pretty
easy to say so suppose I have two
signals s1 and s2 that induced beliefs
denoted here for which the optimal
action is 1 right and if I just
coalesced these two signals it could
happen that the belief ends up in the
red region right so your optimal action
changes so in particular coalescing a
signal will can change the optimal
action and that's obvious because if you
care about uncertainty and variance if I
reveal less information your variance
goes up and you may no longer want to
choose the same action so basically the
revelation principle fails in particular
this implies that the action
recommendations are no longer enough and
we
don't have an LP formulation to find the
optimal signaling mechanism so it's
unclear what to do right so so so
basically the questions that posed now
are like how does one find the optimal
signaling mechanism in this setting and
in particular how many signals are
needed in this case and I won't have
time to go into all the technical
details here but the main thing main
contribution that we do is we show that
in this case the optimal signaling
mechanism can be formed from a convex
program right and at most the state
space number of signals are needed for
action typically let much less than this
but this is the main thing and I won't
go into the details of the proof but for
those who are familiar with the Contessa
fication approach we basically instead
of optimizing over the distribution over
believes we optimize over the
distribution means and that basically
gives a convex program right so the
special case that we look at is what is
called the binary persuasion where the
receiver just has to choose action 0 or
1 right so typically think of this as
like a buy don't buy or wait don't wait
right and the sender's prefer is always
action 1 over action 0 so sender always
prefers that the receiver buys the
product or waits for the service no
matter what the state of the system is
and we assume here that the receivers
utility is convex in their belief so
this is a pretty mild assumption and in
this case we can actually show that we
do get back a linear programming
formulation like in the expected utility
maximizing case and in particular we
show that there is a canonical
construction for the set of signals
right in particular in the optimal
signaling mechanism you will either
reveal the entire state or you will
induce beliefs between two states so so
just to give an example so consider this
where a customers have to decide whether
to wait in a queue for service or not
and their utility is something that
depends on their expected value and the
standard deviation of the waiting time
and the service
provided is providing the queue length
information in this case we can show
that the optimal signaling mechanism for
example will require six different
signals that will induce the join action
optimal action and one signal that will
induce the leave action right so you
need to cut these these different
signals here I'm denoting in different
colors basically this means that if the
queue length is 2 with probability 1/2
tell the customer tell the receiver
I don't know magenta it says Brown
something like that right and so on so
with this I will stop here and yeah the
paper is thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
hi my name is Maria NOLA and I'm from
University of Edinburgh and today I'm an
economist and I Vic on mechanism design
so I will talk about the rule of beliefs
in transfer design that's my main topic
and to just to give you the notations
and also some pre-med tells about
mechanism design is all about one way to
think about mechanism design is that it
is the engineering side of game theory
there is typically a hypothetical or an
actual designer assumed in these
problems who has a certain social goal
in his mind this can be optimized
revenues this can be efficient
implementation for now let's just say
that the social goal is given by a
function f which math maps the state of
uncertainty into an allocation X now
typically in a mechanism design
environment there are multiple agents
whose preferences may depend on the own
private information theta I but it may
also depend on private information of
other agents and this is where adventure
li gives the valuation over the
allocation that is given by the social
goal to now in this environment in
mechanism design environment especially
with private information that is with
incomplete information it is very
important what designer knows about
agents beliefs
now beliefs are way to describe what
each agent knows about others valuations
and what he thinks those other agents
would think about his valuations and
private information too now the typical
modeling assumption in mechanism design
with incomplete information is that the
model these beliefs by a single joint
distribution in the opponent
types which is a different way of
thinking it as the
it's a subjective probability
distribution given and known to the
designer and come only known to the
agents now this is the caustic modeling
framework and it has known there many of
the implementation results are very
sensitive to this come on prior
assumption these common law it
assumptions and so what we do in our
papers with my quote are Antonio Penta
is to take a different modeling approach
to beliefs and instead of fixing a
single subjective trial for each type of
each agent we fix a set of possible
joint distributions over opponent types
this way giving a more flexible more
various possible way of modeling beliefs
now a classic mechanism design
environment as described in this
abstract formulation can be easily
mapped to more practical problems
problems which obviously include as we
have heard many talks today
include auctions taxation public goods
provision and in all of these problems
what's very important to notice is that
the main issue for the designer is an
informational problem the designers
would love to know all these private
information held by the agents and if he
would know that information then he
would easily be able to set the social
goal but because he doesn't know that
information the first order task of the
designer is to incentivize to create
create a mechanism create a game
environment in which agents can
truthfully reveal this information or at
least behave based on this information
so the way to describe or The Economist
say this is that in a transfer design
environment when we look into direct
mechanisms the designer needs to make
sure that incentive compatibility now as
we strangle mentioned yesterday to
incentive compatibility basically in a
transfer design environment peels down
the environment transfer schemes and
this formulation that I'm describing
here is probably many of you already
know and are familiar with from the
auction theory literature but it easily
and straightforwardly at the extent to
arbitrary environments with possibly
interdependent valuation and it is just
saying that stating that exposed
incentive compatibility which is the
relevant motion for belief free
implementation requires using this very
particular uniquely determined transfers
which mirrored evaluation functions and
basically compensate back for the term
that was depending on the truth data I
type instead of data being reported in
the
valuation function now what we find in
our papers is that under this rich model
of belief restrictions the corresponding
notion be incentive compatibility req
virus
similarly fixed transfer schemes but
gives a little bit more flexibility to
the designer so it's still the case that
the incentive compatible transfers
cannot be very different from the
valuing ex-post incentive compatible
transfers however that could be an extra
term
it must be an additive modification of
the original ex post incentive
compatible transfers but this additive
modification necessarily must be a
belief based term which means that this
key I function at the truth telling
profile for every possible belief of
agent I we tried Tita I must be zero so
this is if you try to think about it
it's kind of instructive in in multiple
ways one is that it shows us that with
some information about beliefs which is
more informative than no information
about beliefs whatsoever it may be the
case that there are more interim
incentive compatible transfer schemes
then exposed incentive compatible
transfer schemes and how many more of
these exposed
interim incentive compatible transfer
schemes the designer can have access to
depends on how much information he has
about the beliefs of the agents now it
is very clear that in this setup the
smaller these be sets are the more
information the designer has about
agents beliefs and the smaller these be
sets are
the fewer of these conditions the easier
it is for these conditions to be
satisfied therefore it is likely that
you can find more ki functions which
satisfy this condition for a belief
based time so I just wanted to highlight
this that the more restrictive B is the
more belief based terms are available
for the design of things in order to
shape the transfers and these belief
based modifications can be useful for
budget balance surplus extraction
sampling for better living and what we
do in all peoples we use these varied
based modifications for full
implementation in the first people we
find conditions under which one can
eliminate strategic externalities and
thereby guarantee full implementation
and in a second new people for which
we'd have to trust available already we
look into the assumption of identical
but unknown distribution and we find
that even there you can find belief
based terms to achieve full
implementation whereas you could meet
information of items until there may be
two more futures that I wanted to
highlight one of them is that this
belief base modifications can be quite
robust
in fact many off or suggested
implementations and transfer designs it
is the case that even if this ki KI
function the condition only holds
approximately so the expected value of
this ki function had the truth profile
is not necessarily known to be as vero
but it forced between a small integral
close to zero then the resulting
implementing transfer still elicits a
nearby type
and one of the other interesting results
is that on the identical but unknown
distributions we are able to
characterize the full set of ki
functions which are available for the
designer to do this transfer
modifications and wages we have this
full characterization we can study
different notions of robustness and what
we find interestingly is that for
different notions of robustness one of
them is robustness to limited depth of
reasoning another one which we consider
is robustness
[Applause]
yes my name is Francisco and I'm an
economist from Paris and I'm
specializing these days on social
networks so this is going to be a paper
about social networks and this is joint
work with my students at in chibok so
I'll try to look at Dorotea and and stay
during the ten minutes so the point of
the paper is basically to try and see
what happens when you have a planner and
the objective of the planner is to
target agents in a social network so
what I mean by targeting can be
different things so one interpretation
for example is that agents what the
social network describes are synergies
in the efforts that the agents are going
to provide so if I provide some effort
and my neighbor provides some effort as
well then this is going to increase the
amount of the output that we can create
so that's one example a second example
and that's they are referred to work
that I've done in the past and Ozanne
has done in the past too is the idea
that you have consumption externalities
among agents or some agents benefit from
the fact that other agents consume the
same good so one example that you can
think about is a an influencer on the
YouTube video who's going to give his
dog a particular type of dog food and
then everybody else is going to look at
that influencer and do the same thing so
that's another example of influence and
price discrimination then is going to be
what agents want to do in the network so
when people started looking at that they
looked at it in a context in which the
network was known and recently people
have started asking questions what how
can you do that type of targeting or
discrimination if you only know part of
the network and what we're looking at in
this paper is actually a very particular
very specific type of incomplete
information you have about the network
it's the idea that you have access to
the architecture of the network in the
form of anonymous information so what
you know is for example that the network
is a star but you don't know which agent
what the location of agents in the
network is going to be so you don't know
which of the agents is at the hub of the
star which are the agents are peripheral
agents in the star and so on so think
about it as an extreme version of
privacy restrictions where the only
thing the only information you can have
access to is an information which is
totally without the names of anybody and
the question we ask in that paper is
suppose that actually you only have
access to those restricted information
how is that going to affect your ability
to target or to price discriminate in
the network okay so unfortunately we do
it in a very specific model but it's a
workhorse for many people who have been
working on those targeting in networks
model it's a model where agents have
that type of utility so let me so the
first term is forget about it I mean
those are terms that we need to in order
to have linear response in our best
response functions the last term is the
interesting one it's the term which
captures the externality so gij means
that there is a link between I and J
it's a directed link actually in in our
framework and then xixj means that you
have some complementarity in the efforts
which are made by the two agents or in
the consumption of the two agents now
it's well known that it's not even not
only well known it's very easy to
compute what the solution here is going
to be the solution actually is going to
depend on the matrix G plus GT or G is
the adjacency matrix of the graph so in
particular notice one thing which is
that we have GT here because you create
externalities on the others and the
planner is actually going to want to
increase the amount that you consume or
the amount of effort that you put in
order to make sure that you have those
positive externalities so in particular
note
one thing which is that the planner is
always going to ask you to do more than
what the private agents would like to do
okay as I said the planner only sees the
network architecture the agents for the
most part only know their location in
the network I won't have time to talk
about it but I can talk about it offline
what happens if they know more and the
planner wants to elicit from the agents
information about the location so that's
the that's the novel part of the paper
is that you're going to have that
mechanism when you try to have the
agents explain what they have and I mean
give you the information about the
location you can think about it as you
have locations in it in the network and
you won't you can offer a menu of
contracts where Excel is going to
correspond to the contract for the agent
located at L and agents choose among
that menu of contracts and let's say
that if two agents ask for the same menu
you realize that something is wrong it
could not be that actually two agents
are at the same location so then you can
punish them that's going to be in fact
what you're doing here is that you're
using the correlation among agents types
to punish them as you would do in a
crema MacLean type mechanism okay so
think about that I mean the paper is
more general but think about that as the
implementing the mechanism that we used
to implement is just going to be that
menu of contracts that people can choose
from okay
first incentive compatibility means that
actually you choose the right location
and the first proposition it's a known
it's a no starter because actually any
contract that you can offer is going to
be exposed to incentive compatible here
and the reason for that is just that you
can punish agents from lying and because
you have correlation no two agents can
be in the same location so you can
immediately if you look at ex post
incentive compatibility then clearly so
so that's not what you want so let me
move one step further
and think about agents jointly deviating
so think about the agents join team is
for mister
courting one thing I can do is basically
I can exchange with one of you pretends
that I'm at the location of one of you
and vice versa and now this is actually
potentially more interesting the reason
why it's potentially more interesting is
that you have a misalignment between the
social and the private incentives the
agents would not want actually to they
do not want to make too much effort and
the planner forces you to make a lot of
effort now again this is a non-starter
because for reasons that I can explain
offline any the optimal contract the
g-star that you can choose is actually
going to be group incentive compatible
at least for groups of size two or three
we don't know for four and more but we
suspect that that actually it's the same
for four and more but so let's move on
so I move on actually to the notion that
we look at which is group incentive
compatibility with transfers what I mean
by that is that now the difficulty we
had in group incentive compatibility is
that it was hard to make everybody go in
the same direction now let's just look
at the some and allow for transfers
among the deviating group and if you use
the specification that we have then with
linear quadratic utilities in fact the
definition that you have looks like this
so it's not very helpful I guess but
it's a workable definition and one way
to think about it is that it's
definition which says that the contract
is going to be okay it's going to be if
you align in some ways the quantities
that the agents consumed with the
externalities that they benefit from so
you want to give an agent if you give to
an agent who has high externalities a
high consumption then that's going to be
fine he's not going to be willing to
exchange with another agent okay so let
me give you the two results that we have
in the paper the first result is about
what happens when you have a symmetric
influence model so suppose that you have
undirected network
so all the agents have agents have
symmetric influence so if I influences J
then J influences I then the result is
that if you have that symmetric
influence model then the optimal
contract is always going to be group
incentive compatible with transfers so
it's not a trivial result but what it
captures is the idea that actually you
will then align if an agent has a higher
quantity it means that he benefits from
higher externalities the problem appears
when you have completely non symmetric
situations so let me look at the class
of networks which have very very non
symmetric structure directed nested
neighborhoods which means that you have
one set of influencers on the top they
influence everybody but they're not
influenced by anyone then you have a
hierarchy you have the level two who
don't influence one but they influence
everybody below and so on and so forth
well in that particular setting you can
show that the optimal contracting star
is going to be incentive compatible with
trends without transfers but if you
allow agents to make transfers then you
are going to I mean that that is very
bad in terms of efficiency because you
end up being forced to choose a uniform
contract for everybody the same quantity
eggs for everybody anything else
actually is subject to manipulation by
groups of agents
[Applause]
Oh
all right good afternoon everyone and
thanks for hearing me here my name is
Rosanna canto down I am achoo delighted
to give this talk after Francis and
Chris persuasion Francis talked about
networks I'm going to talk about
persuasion in networks so I'm going to
dive right into the model this is a
teary talk I will be thinking about an
abstract setting where I have an
underlying social network nodes in this
network will correspond to players in a
game and these agents are going to take
binary actions if agent I takes action 0
her payoff is 0 if she takes action 1
her payoff is equal to the state plus a
network externality term so the second
term captures the number of agents in my
neighborhood who also take action 1 now
the states is distributed according to a
known distribution and it belongs to a
sub interval of the reals and agents do
not observe the state prior to taking an
action so in the absence of any further
information information agents take
actions ways to maximize their expected
payoffs we will focus on the problem of
an information designer who actually
sends informative signals to the agents
ways to influence their decisions in
particular I'm going to assume that the
designer commits to a public signaling
mechanism by that I mean everybody
observes the same signal that shares an
informative signal s once the state is
realized so it is in the Bayesian
persuasion setting that Chris was also
working in so thinking about a public
signal is just a mapping from the state
to a signal so a function f that map's
each state T to a signal s given the
state realization and therefore the
signal realization agents update their
posterior posterior beliefs and play a
game with slightly different payoffs
the designer tries to choose this
mapping between the state and the signal
so as to maximize the induced expected
activity so the research question I have
here is what adoptable public signaling
mechanisms look like and how they depend
on the network structure if you want to
think about the concrete application
thinking about agents in a social
network a seller is promoting a product
that exhibits local network
externalities the quality of the product
is a priori unknown and
platform can commit to sending
informative signals about the product
like through a expert review system so
as to maximize the total number of
adapters it fits into the framework that
I'm discussing today so what the top 10
public signaling mechanisms look like
given a mechanism agents play a game of
incomplete information there might be
multiple equilibria following the
literature if there are multiple
equilibria I'm going to focus on the
standard preferred equilibrium that is
I'm going to break ties in favor of the
equilibria that are most favorable to
the designer but let's start to think
about what these equilibria look like
fix the mechanism fix the realization of
the signal agents update their posterior
they base the play a game where the
pills look like this one important thing
is that this is a super modular game
it's a game of strategic
complementarities and it has a largest
equilibrium that we are going to exploit
in particular since I am focusing on
standard preferred equilibrium really in
order to pin down this equilibrium for
each signal realization I need to look
at the largest equilibrium of this super
modular game where the largest possible
number of agents end up taking action
one so what do the largest equilibria of
this game look like but it's also easy
to characterize suppose that the
posterior mean is -5 if I have a group
of agents if I had a committee of ages
and underlying network each of which
have five or more connections within the
community it's an equilibrium for all
these ages to take action one because
they will benefit sufficiently from the
network externalities that will outweigh
the this utility of -5 due to low state
and it will justify their taking action
one if there are multiple such
communities the largest one will be the
set of agents that take action one I
take a little of this super modular game
and this object that I'm describing to
you actually has a name in graph theory
it is the K core of the underlying
network for K equals to 5 formally caker
is the maximal induced subgraph they're
all nodes in the network 1/2 degree of
this K and I can characterize the
equilibria of this promoter game in
terms of the cores of the underlying net
network therefore I can characterize the
standard preferred equilibria of the
game that I
in the previous slide in terms of the
course of the network why do I care
well if it is the case that for any
mechanism and any signal realization the
set of agents who take action one
corresponds to the core of the
underlying network then following a
revelation principle type of logic I can
establish that in there exists an
optimal mechanism right their signal
realizations correspond to the course
and for signal realization K the agents
in the cake or of the underlying network
find it optimal to take action one so I
started with a general information
design problem where I was trying to
figure out an arbitrary mapping from the
state to signals and here what I'm
saying is that you can actually
substantially restrict the course of
mechanisms to focus on in particular the
set of possible signal realizations
should just correspond to the course of
the underlying network so that is a
really nice structure because now my
information design problem simplifies to
the following I have a set of possible
state realizations all I have to do is
to go ahead and partition that such that
when the states belongs to the Kate
partition element I send out signal Kay
all the agents in the cake or finite
optimal to take action one right that's
what I need to do I need to figure out
how to partition the set of possible
states to partition elements that are
associated with different course well
how do I do that here's a mathematical
formulation I'm maximizing or partitions
such that when the state belongs to the
Kate partition element I send signal Kay
agents in the cake or take action one
and I get a reward of RK which is the
cardinality of the cake or I can't have
arbitrary partitions it d'Ovidio least
it has to be the case that when I send
signal K agents in the cake or find it
optimal to take action one that is the
induced posterior mean should be large
enough now we can write the formulation
of this type always but there's a
fundamental difficulty how do I solve
this problem the set of partitions of
search over is actually very large to
sidestep that difficulty and get a an
understandin structure of the optimal
mechanism I follow a two-step approach
step number one I'll work with a convex
relaxation of this problem step number
two given the optimal search to this
session I'm going to lift it I'm going
to reverse engineered optimal mechanism
and the key observation is the following
if you'll get a problem of this type
there are real two quantities that
matter the probability with which I sent
a signal and the induced posterior
expectation so it's a post optimizing
all partitions I'm going to go ahead and
direct the optimize over PK the
probabilities and ZK the induced
posterior expectation under the
mechanism of course these objects are
related they need to satisfy some
constraints and I'm going to go ahead
and impose some constraints and this is
a finite dimensional optimization
problem it's a simple convex program
this is an important distinction
actually in information design
literature you'll often see some linear
programs it's a terry written but when
the state is a continuum like the
sitting I am in usually these are
infinite dimensional optimization
problems that are hopeless
whereas here I truly have a finite
national optimization problem and so to
characterize the flow mechanism and this
is a relaxation in the sense that any
partition induce the feasible P KSDK
tuple but not vice versa turns out
though that this relaxation is tight and
the proof is constructive in the paper I
show that you can take an optimal
solution to this problem and using an
algorithm I provide you can construct
our optimal partition and the mechanism
and not only that but also by exploiting
the structure of this optimization
problem you can actually show that
optimal mechanisms always admit a real
nice structure they and a peculiar
structure actually they always admit a
double interval structure by this what I
mean is the following you take the set
of possible state realizations and with
each signal realization or with each
color of the underlying network you
associate up to two intervals for
instance in this example it's the
facebook sub Network from the snapped
webpage I computed the course sold my
optimization problem and with some cores
of the network with 30 first score for
instance I am adopting mechanism
Associates 2 subintervals of the set of
states and whenever the realization of
the state is in one of the pink
intervals I send signal 31 agents in the
31st core end up taking action one with
some course I have a single interval
associated interval with others I have
twist
oh [ __ ] intervals but never three but
because of this double interval
structure it is the case that agents
some agents will end up taking action
one for low stakes for high states but
not for the medium states which is quite
counterintuitive if you think about that
right agent takes action one for low and
high states but not working medium
states so here's where I stop this is
the teaser for the rest of the results
in the paper speaking to Dean's point
yesterday I don't actually need to know
the network structure to do some of
these things in particular for large
random networks I'll show that using
only the degree distribution not network
structure but using all the degree
distribution I can characterize or
characterize that synthetic size of the
course and let's include the optimal
mechanisms no refined information needed
just be the distribution the framework
extends to settings where the payoff of
the information designer is an
increasing step function of the
posterior mean her signals in views this
applies to any finite super modular
games
you don't need by any reactions like
what I highlighted in the beginning
similar approach also extends to
settings where I am persuading a single
receiver whose type is private in that
setting the optimal mechanism admits a
laminar interval structure which
generalizes double intervals to
difficult to explain in a minute but
based if they're and private types the
optimal mechanism ends up associating at
most n plus 1 intervals with each signal
realization when there is no private
information M is equal to 1 I recover
the double interval structure so the
previous result
extends quite elegant I'm sorry thank
you very much sir for being overtime
thank you very much for attention
[Applause]
everyone I should do this
so my talk is a very different tuff than
the previous view so in the last three
talks what we had is we had a platform
that wanted to send signals or send
information to people and so the the
people would do what the platform wants
them to do my talk is really the
opposite is how can the platform design
something such that people give the
platform the information such that the
platform can do whatever it wants to do
and it's in the context of rating
systems which are really information
systems on these online platforms so I
think most of us have probably
interacted with the rating systems but I
have this light up here to show that
there really is a a very large design
space for how we can do rating systems
on platforms sort of you can modify the
question that you ask the answer choices
how many answer choices do we ask
questions on different dimensions you
have text there's really like in an
extremely large design space and we need
a principled way to think through how do
we make decisions to get the information
that we want to get and so that's the
first challenge the second challenge is
maybe I just lied to you and that
empirically a lot of platforms have
shown that basically whatever you do
you're gonna get the same thing you're
gonna get inflated uninformative
readings where most people are getting
the top possible rating most of the time
and so the problem in such a scenario is
that that's really bad information aliy
no matter how you sort of cut it up as
you get you get no distinguishing signal
from the distinguish maybe the best
possible freelancer or the best possible
worker seller or buyer from the worst
possible one so the point of this talk
is these two challenges aren't hopeless
that platforms can design the
information that you get from people and
really it has two parts the first part
is an empirical part is how does change
in the design change in the information
that you're getting how does changing
the rating system change the responses
people are giving and so this is the
experimental part of the paper which is
in which we look at can you actually
change the rating question that you get
that you the
the question that you asked people and
you get different responses
neither Ramesh and I are behavior less
but we think that we sort of came up
with or found a nice solution that seems
to deflate ratings and online platforms
but even if you have something even if
you have sort of a lever you can pull to
change the ratings that you're getting
to change the information then you're
left with really a theory problem which
is how do you connect the ratings that
you're getting or the information that
you're getting to something that you
really care about as a platform so
whatever the objective of the platform
is and this is really a theory problem
so here what we look at is how does the
feedback distribution that you're
getting of ratings affect how quickly
you learn about participants I'm gonna
focus on the first question the
experimental part for most of the paper
for most of this talk and then I'll sort
of see how we apply it at the very end
so we have an experiment on a large
online labor market that will remain
nameless so the status quo on this
online market is that clients hire
freelancers and then rate them at the
end of the contract and so the feedback
form is pretty long but the status quo
includes a numeric rating already that's
zero to ten and of course like every
other platform it's inflated but like
averages I think over it in half out of
ten so the challenge is can we ask can
we add a new question to this form that
induces non inflated ratings and so the
experiment design is exactly what you
would expect is we add we add an
additional question to the private
feedback part of the form so freelancers
never get to see the answer for this
question and we add six different
questions so we have six treatment cells
and a client is allocated to a single
treatment cell throughout the experiment
period so if a client closes ten jobs
during the period they'll see the same
question in the entire time and then we
observe all ratings over a three month
period which is about a hundred eighty
thousand jobs that were closed
so the first treatment group which is
sort of a pseudo control is adding the
status quo on many of these platforms as
we just added a new question that was
phrased differently than the existing
questions and it's just how would you
rate this freelancer overall and then
zero to five stars the behavioral
intervention that we wanted to test is
many variations of the second treatment
that I have which is we asked the same
exact question how would you rate this
freelancer overall but then the answer
choices were adjectives so they range
from terrible but then sort of we
positive skewed the adjectives so the
equivalent of a 2 out of 5 would be good
the equivalent of a 3 out of 5 which
basically no one gets is great and then
five out of five is the best freelancer
I could imagine the best possible
freelancer and we wanted to see is can
maybe you know Raiders don't want to
like insult their freelancers or insult
the people their rating but by giving
them low ratings but maybe if we
reinterpret it for them they'll give us
more dispersed ratings the rest of the
treatment cells are variations on this
idea okay so what do we see so this
pseudo control of adding this new
numeric question results in exactly what
you would expect from the prior ratings
literature you see over 80% of people
are getting the top possible rating and
then there's like a very slight J curve
where there's another tiny peak at a
zero and then basically nothing in the
middle all the additional treatments
result in radically more dispersed
ratings so here the less than 35.8
personas is less than 35.8 which is so
very few people are now getting the top
possible rating if you're interested the
p-value here is like 10 to the negative
100 it's ridiculous and however so okay
so we have some evidence that we can
provide deflated ratings from just all
we have to do is an intervention of
positive skewing them unfortunately I
haven't told you how informative this is
a possible behavioral tick that's
consistent with this day
is that like 90% of people don't like
reading and so they'll pick a random
word yeah so we have so and then so we
all the addition all the existing form
is still there so we still have the
existing 0 to 10 but then in this new
question we just have the words Plus
this in this specific treatment so
there's 0 to 5 okay so I haven't told
you yet that they're informative I'm
gonna do try to do one pass of it being
informative and then I'll jump into the
theory which tells you like the right
metric of informativeness that you might
care about okay so why we don't think
this is most people not liking to read
is that we can exploit the fact that on
this platform in question the same
client tends to hire the same freelancer
for multiple jobs over a period and over
like a few months and they close each of
those jobs so we might see multiple
ratings in particular we'll see what we
can do is we can look at the first
rating that a client gives a freelancer
in this experimental period and then we
can just observe are they ever hired
again and what we what we should see is
that clients who give the freelancer a
zero saying that they're definitely not
we're tiring or terrible should not
rehire them and then people who give
them fantastic ratings should cut
freelancers who give clients fantastic
ratings should probably rehire them at a
higher rate than normal that is exactly
what we see and in particular you can
also see that these verbal positive
skewed ratings are providing more
information at the very top so sort of
these are hard to interpret but what's
going on is if you get a numeric five
then you're about 20% more likely than
the average freelancer to get rehired
but if you get a the top possible rating
and one of these like verbal scales
you're about 40 to 50 percent more
likely than the average really answer to
get rehired
okay so this is again some evidence of
that we're providing informativeness but
if you're someone like me you're not
really satisfied by these metrics what
you really want is okay what is the
platform actually learning toward the
things that it cares about so I'm gonna
blaze through three theory this is
mostly an advertisement for the paper
and sort of a follow on paper so what
we're gonna assume is in the theory that
we have a joint distribution of the
ratings people receive and the qual and
their true quality and then we make up
some model and which sellers are
accumulating ratings according to this
Joint Distribution and that the platform
is estimates they're rating and then are
ranking and then you can derive large
deviation rates for how quickly this
estimated ranking converges to the true
ranking that you care about and a follow
on paper we basic in a binary setting we
say what if you don't just care about
like the the ranking uniformly but maybe
you care about parts of their ranking
more but I'll not get into that okay so
to apply that to our experiment we need
to have estimates of the true quality
because we need to estimate this Joint
Distribution I mean again to get a skip
how we estimated to quality and then I'm
gonna say but once we do that once we
have this rose we can just compare
scales by their induced large deviation
learning rates and you can indeed see
that so one you get a number now that's
saying this is how much better this this
scale is in other scales and then see
that it matters in a simulated market
for how quickly you're converging to the
true sort of estimating the true ranking
and all and with my takeaway slide again
[Applause]
very fast I appreciate the opportunity
to present this work and I appreciate
you guys all for sticking around
it does not okay so I want to be talking
about mechanism design with correlate
evaluations or fish of methods for
revenue maximization so a common
assumption and mechanism or auction
design is that better evaluations are
independent this holds in almost no
settings of interest and then a more
realistic assumption is that better
evaluations are drawn from some joint
distribution and if you have this tore
distribution and you know it you can do
some pretty incredible things with
mechanism design in fact private
information doesn't have any value
anymore with probability one private
information loses all value under this
correlated setting that's assuming
you're okay with Bayesian mechanisms
which I am and I hope you guys are as
well but uh but in the real world we
don't really know this distribution we
might have some fuzzy idea of what it
looks like or more realistically we
might be able to interact with bidders
over some kind of repeated setting and
and learn this distribution well the
question is how do we design mechanisms
when we are trying to learn this
correlated distribution so what I'm
going to present is an automated
mechanism design a design procedure that
is both computationally and sample
efficient for jointly maximizing revenue
and social welfare when there is
sufficient correlation and so these are
a preview of the simulation results here
in case I don't get to them all right so
just for the sake of exposition we're
going to assume that there's a
monopolist excel or one item there's
going to be a single bidder with type
theta drawn from a discrete distribution
of types and his valuation is going to
be the availa
and then there's going to be an external
signal that is correlated with this type
so this is going to play the role of
potentially other bidders who have
correlated valuations but without all
the complications of having actual other
people this will provide the side
channel in to and to this bidders
information for the purpose of this talk
I'm gonna assume this external signals
binary just thumbs up or thumbs down but
and in the paper it can be an arbitrary
discrete external signal and so we all
know what mechanisms are I'm gonna use a
quasi linear utility which is important
for these kinds of mechanisms and once
we have this we can the optimal design
the Alpha mechanism using a linear
program where we pick our choice of
individuation allottee and incentive
compatibility if you want to extract
full surplus you're going to have to
choose the bayesian mechanisms but and
then we have an allocation constraint so
intuitively what's going on here well I
can encode all the information on the
problem in the on this graph a type is a
dot on this graph the horizontal axis
can be considered a one simplex which is
the beliefs over the external signal
that that type the bitter has when
there's no correlation types are all
vertically aligned meaning they all have
the same beliefs of the external signal
I can also encode different marginal
probabilities using different sized dots
here and in this case the outflow
mechanism would just be take you to
leave an offer where we would sell the
item at to all of the dots above the
line to would buy the item anybody below
would not if you have correlation though
and we use a Bayesian mechanism well
then these dots are no longer vertically
aligned and we can instead of making a
tickler leave at offer offer a
take-it-or-leave-it lottery this line
indicates that the lottery has a charges
a price of 5 when thumbs up is seen and
a price of zero when thumbs down is seen
which means that anywhere your expected
payment is anywhere along this line and
this is how we okay so I have to end
quickly because the battery is running
out the so this is how you
full circles this is how you get rid of
the value of private information is that
an expectation each of these guys pays
their full value and it doesn't matter
what they report right and it turns out
we don't need any say we don't need this
these these dots to be very you know far
separated they can be quite close
together and we just end up with
lotteries with extreme payments which
you may or may not be comfortable with
but we still an expectation extract full
surplus so this is the creamer claim
result from 1985 if you're not familiar
with it it's a it's a wonderful paper so
what if we have access to samples now
and there was sufficient correlation why
am I saying that we need sufficient
correlation well in a paper and a
mustard on some teen we showed that if
you don't have sufficient correlation
learning is impossible here if you have
a continuous set of possible
distributions you're trying to learn
from so the command McClane a result of
of arbitrary correlation getting rid of
the value of private information is not
true when you're trying to learn from
the continuous set of distributions or
even just an infinite accountably
infinite set of distributions so what we
actually observe we don't observe the
true distribution we observe these
orange dots which is a reported value
and we and external signal and the
relative sizes of these dots might
indicate the relative times we see that
particular sample so given these dots I
can estimate the distribution maybe this
blue dot here and I'll have some
interval under which this said this
belief is consistent with that estimate
right some kind of confidence interval
if you will around this I'm going to
call these confidence intervals an
epsilon consistent set of distributions
which just means that there's a set
under which the true distribution is in
that set with high probability so once I
do this well I can I can just design the
naive mechanism where I just optimize
according to my expected distribution my
um my expected distribution but if the
true distribution looks like this which
is in this consistent set then for this
guy down up here isn't I don't really
lose that much revenue but I lose a
little bit not a big deal but this guy
down here no longer participates because
it's not individually rational anymore
so the obvious solution to this is to
this line a little bit when you lower
this line you lose expected revenue but
you never end up in this catastrophic
situation where people choose not to
participate so it turns out we can
design these mechanisms by modifying the
linear program we end up with an
infinite set of constraints but we use a
a constraint generation approach to show
that we can solve this in polynomial
time and so great and the question is
how they how do they perform well we
need sufficient correlation and it's not
Pearson correlation the relevant
condition is around the kind of
sufficient linear separation of these
conditional distributions so if we have
three possible external signals and this
is the two simplex then that condition
states that these conditional
distributions are sufficiently far away
from the convex set of other conditional
distributions so it's kind it's this
notion of you sufficiently satisfy the
original Cromer claim condition not just
not just satisfy but satisfied by enough
if we have this condition we can show
that we can compute a nearly optimal
mechanism and with a polynomial number
of samples it's not a small polynomial
but but at least as a polynomial okay so
we we use simulated data to evaluate
this approach it's a discretized
bivariate normal distribution we sample
from the distribution it's some amount
of times these Bayesian methods
estimators efficient we cannot calculate
empirical confidence intervals and then
we can vary correlation other other
things and what we see here is that if
you take a you know if you just look at
the x post of my slides gonna end up in
here so if you take just the next post
mechanism and you know I look at the
optimal twist mechanism given your
estimate of the distribution
you never do all that well you actually
barely do any better than
and then just ignoring the correlation
altogether if you take a Bayesian
mechanism and just kind of neat naively
optimized for it then you end up
dramatically overfitting the error bars
are almost Bayesian mechanism or just
for just gigantic because it's it's
effectively overfitting and that our
approach smoothly and converges to the
the full surplus extraction and does
significantly better than than any other
two approaches and consistent with our
results about the degree of correlation
being important for learning we show
that a weak we confirm that the more
correlated the setting the the quicker
it is to learn these mechanisms alright
so there are other applications and for
each of research directions but I'm
having to talk about those offline so
thanks very much for staying and
listening and I'm happy to take any
questions afterwards the delay time is
only because of the the technicalities
between Tosca
so have a very nice evening and see you
all tomorrow for the last day of the
workshop right